hey y'all it's andrew couch here and
this is not
an actual tidy tuesday video instead i
wanted to make a video where i rank
um common data visualizations and i
actually got this inspiration from doing
some movie
tier lists with a friend of mine and
while i was doing it i thought it'd be
kind of fun to do it with the data
visualizations
so i created a little tier
list from the teamrecorder.com with just
a bunch of uh
data visualizations i actually got it
from the r
graph gallery um in the chart types so i
figured like
this is a pretty good um kind of like
array
of data visualizations are pretty common
so i'm pretty bad with actual data
visualization names
so i'm just going to keep this on the
side so i can kind of say the official
name
and then i'm going to give my thoughts
about the actual chart type
and where i see it uh being ranked as uh
as for the actual rankings i think i'm
going to kind of say it's like
ranked by usefulness and effectiveness
of a data data visualization
but as we know most data visualizations
are important and they all have you know
their own use cases so
this is definitely not like a an
objective measurement where you
shouldn't be using a certain type of
data visualization
it's definitely a case-by-case basis so
unfortunately some of these charts are
pretty
some of these pictures are pretty small
so uh i'll definitely try to
refer to this the my little um
uh chart table right here so we can kind
of see in a little bit bigger format but
i know these charts pretty well so we
can first start up
with this um so right here we have a
little scatter plot
um let me see if we can find it right
here so we have a little scatter plot
again and i think the scatter plot is
basically one of the best visualizations
you can have
and i would definitely rank it as s-tier
as is i think
when you're looking at numerical data or
just continuous data in general you
generally will make a scatter plot
to do some type of pairwise um
relationship
so i think the scatter plot is just a
great plot to use
um as is okay
so next is this um was this like a uh
kind of a dependency or
what kind of plot is it called it's
called a uh
let's see here it's a uh let's see a
heart
a dendogram so it's called a dendogram
and they look like this and i kind of
get
a dendogram because there it's all about
hierarchy data you know you have kind of
like a tree
and then you can see how these end nodes
are related to this branch
and it's really just essential branch in
general and although i think
it is kind of useful when you're looking
at like network analysis and stuff like
that
i i don't think it's a very common data
visualization technique
and frankly it's a little confusing to
actually visualize
um so i'm going to rank this actually
kind of as like a c
i don't think it's really commonly used
um
as is uh just because there's a little
bit better ways to do it
um for me i definitely like a like uh a
a uh sanki or sinksy gram
diagram right here but i'm going to rank
it right now at c
um just because i think in general it's
kind of hard to plot out and
uh in like gdpr so you have to go
through other packages and also
uh it's kind of confusing to actually
look at um just from like a layman's
term like
if you're not really into data even when
you see that it's a little confusing
okay so this is the next one is the heat
map
which i think heat maps are actually
pretty underutilized
i think heat maps in general are pretty
useful to look at
um especially when you're dealing with a
lot of data
so when i have a lot of data generally
i'll try to bin it or group it
and that'll cause that'll allow me to
basically uh um
see if there's any relationships that i
want to look at
so a heat map when we bring up heat map
heat maps are definitely pretty easy to
make
you just use gm tile and use the fill
and you can add a lot of stuff to it
so not only is it useful from like you
know using uh
two groups but it's also kind of useful
because you can condense it both on
like a categorical variable but also
numerical variable
additionally if you're looking if you're
working with a lot of geospatial stuff
um actually heat maps are pretty useful
uh because you've kind of been in these
little things and you can actually see
um a lot of stuff going on
so i actually really like heat maps i
don't show them a lot just because uh
i think heat maps are kind of uh
usually i'll do a scatter plot but he
maps in general i'm gonna rank him as an
a tier
okay so the next is i believe like a was
it a
a bubble plot maybe like this thing
right here um
let me pull up a bubble plot um
okay oh actually it's maybe it's called
a uh let me find it
um yeah it's called i guess a circular
only circular packing or circular tree
map
so for me i i generally enjoy
um these type of plots like from a
data journalism from a data journalistic
standpoint i think they're really
compelling uh you seem a lot like the
economist and stuff like that
but in general if you're doing like an
eda
i don't think they're very useful or
they're for the amount of effort you put
into creating these like
um these plots um it it does take a lot
of effort to do it and you'd probably
have to do it in like d3 or something
like that
so in general i think these are actually
better than
say this plot right here but
i i wouldn't do it every day in my
day-to-day
uh edas that being said um i think
another variation the plot is like a be
swarm plot um which are very cool so i
think i would probably rank this
at least above um um this plot
so i do think these think plots are
really cool gdpot does allow
it's kind of like a gm jitter but it's
really not the same thing
okay so for this plot which i believe is
was like an
area line chart right or a stacked area
line chart
and i i really like these charts uh not
only because
it's a good way to compare multiple
groups from like specific like a time
series basis
but it's pretty easy especially when you
do a lot of reordering with the actual
colors to make a pretty good insight and
kind of summarize all of your data into
just one simple plot so
you kind of see an overall visual trend
and you also see you know what
uh components are really driving an
overall trend
so i'm actually going to rank this as
maybe b tier you don't see them
every day at least in my work but i i
generally think these plots are really
cool
um one variation that i actually like is
the um
like a stacked column chart where it's
basically like this but instead of the
um the lines it's actually like a calm
but in general these plots are very good
and they're very compelling uh to use
when you're trying to get some type of
insight from it
so these plots right here um to my left
is i think called like a chord
a chord plot yeah a chord diagram
and i i think chord diagrams
again are one of those plots where you'd
probably see like in the economist
or from a data journalistic standpoint
but when you're actually doing these
types of plots say
doing an exploratory data analysis or
just in data science in general
um it's kind of hard to create
i do think these are very cool um but
you know there's a lot there's the use
case for is always about like networks
and relationships
and i think that's really useful and i
think that if you
were to create a like an article about
it you can write a lot about you know
how you can see these flows of
relationships and their you know
degrees of freedom uh with their
relationships between you know multiple
groups
but if you have this plot say like in a
presentation to like
you know stakehold business stakeholders
it takes a lot of time to kind of figure
out the so what
of of this plot right even when i'm
looking at this i think this is from
um like the gap minder package maybe or
something like that but
again it's something where yeah yeah we
can see south asia and west asia
there's something connected to it but i
don't really know what to really get out
of it from like the other
other relationships right oh so through
migration
so i think that's kind of interesting
but again it's something where
uh it takes a lot of time to look at and
obviously you can see how the arrows can
show those relationships with it with
each other
but again it's it's a little confusing
and you wouldn't want to do it every day
or you wouldn't like create that
um you couldn't create that
visualization pretty very fast
at least in my opinion so again i'm
going to probably rank this a little bit
above this
um maybe maybe below
uh the bubble plot the this chart or the
circle tree chart
um so you may notice right here for this
next plot we have two of the same
scatter plots
this scatter plot or one of these
scatter plots is actually like a
a uh an animated scatter plot so one of
the famous
um visualizations using animation is
like i think like the gap minder of like
um life expectancy or mortality rates
and it shows how the trend of
all these countries changing throughout
time and how we as an
entire society has have uh lowered our
mortality rates and it's very
interesting it's very compelling and
it's a really good story and
good presentation but animated charts
just are not good i i really don't think
anime charts have a place
in a lot of like data science workflows
um it's mostly
to do one centered presentation and even
that
uh there there are a little bit better
ways to do it
one way to do it is mostly kind of like
a uh
a basic scatter plot and just have a and
b and have like a connected segment and
you can see how like
hey this this this point went to here
in 10 years um and that makes it a
little bit easier especially when you
have
you know a lot of frames or a lot of
animation time
in it where like if someone stops
looking at it and after 10 seconds you
kind of
lose your train of thought you have to
go back and look at it again
it's not the most the best way to
actually look at and
gain some insight but when it works it
works very well
um so that just because it's like a d
tier it doesn't mean it's a bad
visualization it's just it's really hard
to pull off especially in a data science
workflow
so here is your your simple like line or
time series chart i think
um oh i actually have two of these and i
for me obviously you're just gonna put
it on the the s tier
like any type of relation charts you
know these charts are simple
uh they're simple they get straight to
the point you can
visualize an overall trend in seasonal
uh seasonal patterns
it's a solid chart uh i don't think
there's much to really discuss about
that
um i will say i think a problem with a
lot of line charts is
there's a lot of noise and a lot of uh a
gridline stuff that which kind of takes
away from it
one thing i guess i will say about a
good line charts is
to be aware of your scale of the y-axis
so sometimes people do like a log on the
axis sometimes people won't start at
zero they'll start at some other axis
uh some other number and i think kind of
making sure that you you tell whatever
viewer
is looking at the chart to like
understand the scale
uh so that he or she won't be confused
okay so now we have the actual bar chart
and for me my the bar charts are my
favorite chart in general so i
i would consider it the best chart um
just because like i you you deal a lot
with you know categorical variables and
you you generally do a lot of accounting
for me
you know when you think about data
science you think about complex neural
networks
you know crazy asian analysis
um you know a lot of like rigorous
statistics but a lot of it
is just doing simple accounts and simple
accounts can give you a lot of insight
towards your own data set for modeling
towards insight
and towards growth what's driving things
so in general like uh column charts
or bar charts are great for me
personally i prefer the the flipped
comp bar chart where the bars are going
horizontal instead of vertical
just because you can stick your access
names a little bit longer
um but again when you don't have that
many
uh things you know the classical bar
chart is is great
so this chart right here is a 3d chart
um let me see if i can grab an example
from
my little uh reference so let's see it's
like
i guess yeah 3d chart right here i'm
actually gonna
do that
i think it's just better for me to
search it um whenever i need it so
so we have a 3d chart and 3d charts like
this
are terrible that you need to have three
charts that
you know have a reason to be a 3d chart
for me right here this is just
this would just be a bar chart right
even though it's a pie chart it should
be a bar chart because there's no
the the scale or the the dimensions
don't mean anything right here
but for this right here where you're
doing like you know maybe like a cluster
analysis and you want to see
a lot of interactions i think a 3d chart
is actually
pretty useful um especially when you're
dealing with um
surfaces too with like geospatial stuff
and just in general when you
are trying to do an eda with clustering
i think 3d charts are actually very
useful
um i don't want to use them too much
because i use i just do a bunch of
pairwise
charts but sometimes uh
i'll do a 3d chart and those are always
very interesting to see
so i think in general they're pretty
good i'm gonna put it right there
okay um so this right right here is i
think called like a
was it a spider chart um let me see
where it where it's called what it's
actually called
um yeah a spider or a radar chart um
in general i think spider charts or
radar charts are
are interesting um and i think
a lot of times you could say this could
just be a a bar chart right because it's
just
categories and their values um
a lot of times i would say is that
sometimes you want to compare
multiple groups by multiple categories
i mean having a bunch of spider charts
like this or that
um is actually pretty cool um i think
for
dashboards it's pretty cool to have just
because it looks a little bit more
fresher
and you can store a lot more data um i
guess like per square inch of
information
um with with a raider chart so i think
you see a lot of radar charts in like
sports when you're showing like you know
in baseball like attributes of a player
and or attributes of like teams and
trying to compare the teams uh so i
think raider charts are pretty good
actually i think they're pretty
underrated they're very hard to create
in ggpot but i still think um they have
a lot of their use cases so
i'm actually gonna put this kind of on
the bottom see just because
you know you're not gonna make a lot of
them uh in your in
analysis but when you do need to do it
raider charts are pretty much perfect so
nothing too nothing really too negative
about radar charts
so this chart right here is called a
lollipop chart
and i used to be a pretty big fan of
lollipop charts because
uh from a data visualization standpoint
you know they take a lot of
i guess the um yeah
it prevents it it solves a lot of issues
with a calm chart where
when you have a lot of groups it can
kind of be a lot
of information to take in so when you
have a lollipop chart
it's you can have more columns basically
and it won't be as distracting for
a a reader audience additionally you
since you have the little point or the
little like
i don't know the end of the lollipop you
can actually add some more data to it
which can make it pretty useful so you
kind of have a column chart and you can
also add a little bit more to the column
chart
um so the flip to all or the the
football always pretty good
um a variation of it is the the dumbbell
plot we essentially have two lollipops
um
going on both ends and i think those or
the dumbbell plots are really good
obviously for comparing things
among multiple groups so if you're doing
like anovas and stuff like that
i think lollipop charts are very
lollipop or dumbbell charts are really
good
i'm used to data visualization and
something you really can't do
with a bar chart um very well so i i'm a
huge fan of uh lollipop charts i
actually might put it
above the heat map so just for now
i'm probably gonna go by here i'll go
through here again
and maybe do a little bit of rearranging
and talking about why but i think right
now a lollipop chart is is definitely a
tier
chart okay
um so this chart right here um i need to
figure out what it's
called it's i guess it's called a
circular
bar plot um
i i don't like these at all i think they
look cool
so again very useful for data
visualization
but it's just needlessly messy um
like it's kind of cool how we have like
different subgroups right with d
a a b c d among these and you can kind
of see it right here but
it's kind of hard to compare like mr 11
and group b
versus you know group c's mr 48
like how is this one bigger you do a lot
of um
i'm searching and i think this is very
cool for
maybe like a a cover of some data
journalistic data journalism
um magazine but from just from a
usability standpoint it's it's
way more style over function um
i think it's probably the worst spot to
use i don't think there's any
use i don't think there's any reason why
you would want to do a circular
bar chart over like a faceted bar chart
unless it's pure aesthetics so um
yeah not a big fan of it um i
i i don't think it's a very useful chart
in general
um the donut chart so
i i there's a lot of uh of
discussions about you know in general if
you're into data visualization
you know bar uh uh pie charts are the
worst
part pie charts are terrible uh they're
bad for comparing things
the only time a pie chart is kind of
useful is when you have like
one large group with like two other
small groups
but in general a a pie chart can be
a bar chart that being said
i think donut charts are a little bit
better than
pie charts but just only slightly um
i don't think they're very good i i do
think they look cool
on on dashboards but they're not they're
they're still
[Music]
i i'm not really a fan of them i'm gonna
put them basically below
the animated charts because sometimes
you want a little bit more
visual uh a variety
you know you can't just have but you can
and i mean i i would actually prefer
a dashboard that's just all bar charts
but sometimes you know you might want to
do maybe like especially like finance
you know maybe put like a donut chart
right there
uh and and that that's fine you know
it's it's nothing i'm gonna get
really angry about but you know i think
most people would rather just have a bar
chart
um but you know vps probably like it
so with the pie chart i've already kind
of gone through my tired of a pie chart
i think they're pretty bad i think they
still have a
like one very specific use case so it's
going to be obviously below the donut
chart because
whenever you think even if you want to
do a pie chart for its use case
a donut chart will be better but i still
think it's a little bit better than the
the the circular bar chart
just because like this could be a pie
chart
and it'll look a little bit better but
realistically they should all be bar
charts
okay so this chart right here i
i didn't really see it or maybe maybe i
did see it uh
no so this is like a pairwise chart
uh which basically shows all the
pairwise interactions and distributions
uh you can see it in gg ally um pretty
well so let me see if you have a little
article so gg pairs
uh for me i love gg pairs i think
generally when i'm
working with a lot of columns and you
kind of are frozen
or you have so many so many features
that you want to look at and
understand the relationships but you
don't really know where to start right
you know you don't know if you want like
oh maybe i should plot out the
distribution of this
this column or maybe i should see the uh
the scatter plot of this column
between these two things uh i think gg
ally
is basically the thing you should be
doing because you get a high level
summary of all the
relationships all the distributions
between like you
between your columns you're able to you
know
color it and and look at all the stuff
so basically this is like a
like one brief eda in one plot um it
does take a while but
it's it's definitely worth doing and it
really um alleviates all the manual
plotting work you actually have to do
so i consider it s tier it's not better
than the line chart or the uh the
scatter plot because
those charts basically make up the
pairwise plot
but it's still pretty good um
i don't know why i have two of these i
think i'm just gonna put them right next
to each other
uh because i think these are the same
thing
yeah they look like the same thing okay
um area charts
so i think i i in general i think area
charts are kind of
interesting uh when area charts like
this one right here
i i i'm not really a huge fan of it
right here
unless if it is obviously if you're
doing a a density
um but i think this is mostly just like
a long chart with area it's not
necessarily a density plot
so for that i still think it's pretty
good
what i will say is like when you have it
kind of crossing the axis like this
i think these charts are very useful um
and a line chart won't really capture
this kind of a relationship where you
can
kind of see the actual periods of like a
positive value in periods of a negative
value
it's much easier to look at it with an
area chart than it is with
a line chart so i still really like them
i don't see them a lot but just because
i don't see them a lot doesn't mean that
they're not useful
so i'm going to put it maybe i'll put it
right there
okay um so this is right here like a hex
map
and i really like uh hex maps so let me
grab that and hex bin map kind of solves
a lot of geospatial
problems so a lot of times when you're
visualizing
data on a geospatial or like you know
just anything to do with like
locations a lot of times you see a
relationship
that's basically tied towards population
or or so
area and stuff like that so
a good i think that these uh hex bin
maps solve is that they basically can uh
convert all of the little states or or
regions that you want to
do into a the same area or same size of
of a point so this makes it so you can
kind of look at it and not be
i guess uh skewed towards larger area
larger areas right so with texas texas
is a huge
state it's in california but once we
normalize it to these hex hexagons and
then we normalize it by population
we get a clear picture of what we want
to look at
like say marriage rates so i'm a huge
fan of
uh these hex bin plots i actually
started off my data visualization
journey creating hex spots for iowa
counties uh so i
they always have a a uh
you know a place in my heart so i guess
the big
issue with a lot of these hex plots is
that there is not a lot of hexbots
uh available and obviously there's
probably a plot there's probably some
type of uh
uh library that can kind of condense it
uh
sort of but you know a lot of these
state ones
uh or accounting things you kind of have
to make it yourself by hand
and that takes a long time so if you
have if you find a plate a hex map
that meets your you know your your data
that you need need it for
then it's extremely useful but sometimes
you just don't have it
uh and that can be a problem so i'm
going to put it right there yeah i'll
probably
probably
just because you don't see them too
often and a lot of times you won't have
the ability to do a hex map
but when you can they're very nice um
they're very nice to have so
so the next one is like a network plot i
believe
um let me see if i yep we have a network
bot
um so yeah networks i think they're very
cool they're very interesting uh and
there's a lot of
data visualization theory that goes into
network plots so
you know when you're plotting on a
network where should a be relative to b
or where should e be relative to c you
know so
unless if you have specific coordinates
you know if you're working with like
for me transportation where we have
these coordinates it's kind of hard to
determine that and sometimes they'll
just do it randomly
like that sometimes they'll make it a
circle um
and sometimes there's different
algorithms that will do it so there's a
lot of data theory
databases visualization data
visualization theory that goes into
network plots
uh i find them very useful in my in my
work
uh so it's definitely a thing that you
should always have conscious in your
brain
uh when you're when you're learning data
science but
you don't see them too often but they
are very useful and
there's a lot of theory that goes into
it so i'm actually gonna put it pretty
high
just above the uh and probably below it
uh the heat map
so they're very cool plots ggpot
doesn't have a great support for network
plots
but igraph does so if you ever need to
do a lot of network analysis um
going into the igraph library which i
believe is like a subset
or a you know a json ggplot library
okay so the next one is the sankey sinky
plot
uh i find cindy plots to be very cool
but you don't use them a lot uh i think
if you're doing a lot of like network
like process analysis
uh then a sankey plot would be very
useful
so maybe for like more managers and
stuff like that or
just in general anything that has to do
with like a process
uh sandy pots are pretty useful
um you see it a lot with like you know
your salary and where it goes to and
stuff like that you see a lot on like
our slash data is beautiful that being
said
i don't do a lot with these stinky bots
i don't even know how to make one
in uh in our so although i think it's
good
i i don't use a lot and i don't find it
to be that
uh i don't i guess i don't find it to be
useful in my own work i can see how it
could be very useful for a very specific
task
um so i think i'm going to put this
maybe below the 3d plot
on honestly i might switch i'm going to
switch these out right there
because i think the does the more thing
about the more think about how the
writer and spiderbot
is going to be used a little bit more in
a data science workflow then i guess
thank you
but okay
so this next plot i believe is called
like uh was it a parallel
plot or something like that yeah a
parallel plot
i actually and parallel plot is
basically a line chart but you have
on your x axis like categorical
variables
um i find parallel plots to be actually
pretty useful uh when trying to
visualize distributions
uh among many samples
characteristics so right here they're
showing it off like a uh
was it the iris data set and you can
kind of see how each line represents a
sample
and the y-axis represents that
features value for that sample and you
can kind of see the variation among
samples
and also the variation among species
right so
i actually find these pods to be very
useful and i think
honestly underutilized um a lot in our
data science workflow
so these spots are very i think they're
very nice especially with like
uh if you're doing a bayesian analysis
these are plots are pretty useful to
look at since you're always trying to
look at like
you know um the variance of a a
of a class or a group so i actually
really like these plots i do make them
probably like once a month uh when i'm
doing an eda so
it's definitely something that you
should consider adding to your toolbox
to use so
i would actually consider this on the
top of a b tier
um the next one is maybe like a what
it's called like a
um uh what's it called a dense yeah
density 2d bot
so density 2d plots again i think
they're pretty cool
i i think they're you
they're basically they're they are
basically the same thing as a his as a
heat map
but it has more to do with actual areas
so like if you're doing a lot of
geospatial stuff
it's pretty useful so for me i
i still think it's it's good that being
said i
i have a preference towards uh heat maps
in general just because the binning is
kind of weird in ggpot
and a lot of the stuff is kind of weird
but we can see how there's a lot of
variations
uh with the uh hex was it the dense 2d
density plots
um and you can you never get an insight
so like what's going on in that hot spot
or
you know stuff like that uh i i don't
like
contour plots as much with these lines
uh even though like
i think most data scientists and
analysts can read it i
i think i'd be hesitant to show it in a
in a presentation because
a lot of times people will misread a
contour plot
and it's better to just have like you
know the brighter the color the
the more the value instead of like oh
the closer the lines that the more
the value is is increased um
so yeah not a fan of contour plots so
the next is was it a uh
uh was it clello a
coral choropleth yeah
choropleth so again if you're doing
a lot of plotting and geospatial stuff
you're gonna do this um generally i
think i would just call it like a pot
of a map and stuff like that but one of
the main problems that you face
with these uh coral black plots is that
when you have these colors you can see
like your eye kind of
darts towards the larger um
countries and not really the actual
colors of it
so it can kind of do a lot of misleading
it can't kind of mislead you
on it right which is why we have you
know the uh the hex
hex maps and stuff like that so i think
they again
they are useful i i'm not saying they're
not useful
but i would always try to prefer a a a
a hex bin plot
so now we're actually at the kind of the
nlp stuff which is the
word cloud um and
for me my friends actually know my
reputation
on um word clouds and the thing is i
i really hate word clouds i think word
clouds
are just terrible i i think they're kind
of weird
and i think that they don't display a
good use of data visualizations
and what i mean by that is one right
here there's way too many colors the
colors don't obviously mean anything
it's just to separate and distinguish
the words
but the size of the words is very hard
to distinguish
right so oil i guess is the biggest word
but
a lot of times the size is also dictated
by
you know the amount of letters a word
has which makes it very hard to compare
you know tokens with each other
so maybe it's it's cool for maybe a
design standpoint if you're trying to
make a
some artwork but for me from a data data
visualization point
it's it's just terrible uh i would
rather have
a column chart that is representative of
that word
right and then maybe have some type of
like lumped other column
so yeah not a fan of word cods
i think they could be interesting if you
want to do like maybe a
dashboard or something like that or just
kind of something for someone to kind of
browse
but for actual insight it's not good um
i would actually consider it
maybe on the tier of like a
pie chart so
this plot right here i believe is like
uh kind of like a
network thing with uh a connection plot
um a connection map i think this is
super niche
uh it's basically the same thing as a
network plot but
you know again use with maps i think
it's a fine plot maybe
a little bit above the hierarchy plots
or whatever
but you're not going to use it every day
it's something if unless if you're in
like transportation you'll use uh
so i don't have much to say about that
okay so this spot right here i think
it's called like a joy plot
or a ridgeline plot which is basically
based off the uh
joy division album so um
these plots are getting more common now
in uh
in in data science right so it's an
unknown pleasures album
um i am a huge fan of a ridgeline chart
because a lot of times you're trying to
compare distributions
of some type of parameter or some type
of value among multiple groups
and although you know ggplot has a thing
where you have the colors and you can
you can decrease the alpha having it as
different lines
makes it way easier to compare values
um i'm a huge fan of it i think it's
honestly one of the
better s-tier plots that i use most most
of the time
so if you're doing bayesian analysis
ridge
ridgeline plots are extremely useful if
you just want to compare distributions
among groups
or among multiple columns uh again
ridgeline plots are great
so i believe this is a was it a density
plot right
let me see yep a density plot oh do i
not have a history oh no i do
uh i like density plots a lot um
so right here this is a time where you
know you don't really need
a ridgeline plot but right here yeah a
ridgeline pot would be pretty
pretty useful because it's kind of hard
to compare these things they're just
kind of stacked together
or you can fasten it like that but i i
really like
density plots if you have uh things like
this
this is a time when ridgeline pots won't
really make any sense so a mirrored
density pot is pretty cool um yeah in
general i like densities
um sometimes i do prefer some binning
just remove the tail ends but
i do enjoy a density plot so i'm going
to compare it to
pretty top of eight here um and then the
histogram right here
uh histograms again
very similar to a density plot but we
have some binning uh
i enjoy a a good histogram
i don't like these histograms where you
can't see any distinguish of the bins so
like
i generally say a color equals white uh
so we have like kind of like this style
but in general i i i do enjoy uh using
i do like uh histograms in general
sometimes i i prefer not to have any
actual bins
and i'll just do a simple bar chart but
when you're doing
bar charts and histograms they're
relatively similar except histograms are
bending it in in groups so
uh i i definitely consider it to be more
at least top
of uh the density plot i think
for me personally i use density pots a
little bit more than histograms but
i i know a lot of other people will use
histograms for density plots so
uh nothing much to say
um what is i'm curious what this is
oh yep this is a bubble plot so bubble
plots are just scatter plots
where the size of the point is increased
and i'm pretty against bubble plots
or i'm in general i'm against changing
the size
as a variable because it's kind of hard
to compare
two circles uh for values uh
because a circle twice the size of
another circle doesn't really look
exactly twice because you have like
radiuses and stuff like that
um so if you are using bubble charts
it's more of just kind of a general
trend not to have
a direct comparison right so it's like
oh these two
these these two bubbles right here are
larger than the other ones what are
those bubbles
but if we want to compare how much
bigger is you know that bubble
compared to this bubble it's not a great
thing to do but again they're very
common
uh they just can't be misused in the
wrong manner which you can say about any
plot but i think these spots are
very easy to mis misuse and misinterpret
where you can kind of um where it's
harder to compare direct
direct samples together
okay so this plot right here i'm uh i'm
actually not sure what this is oh an arc
diagram that's what it's called
um
i i think these plots are kind of pretty
not very hard to figure out what's going
on uh i
if i guess it's supposed to be like a
network plot where you can see how like
a
is being has a relationship with all
these you can see how b has a
relationship with a and e i think that's
cool
um maybe but again this
this plot is harder to understand
compared to this plot
uh so i don't really think i think again
it's more the style over substance stuff
i'm gonna put it right there it's still
better than you know a donut chart
no actually it probably isn't no i'm
gonna put it below uh
below that it's not as bad as this
circular bar chart but it's pretty bad i
i think it's it's it's almost like a
pretentious
like a data visualization where i think
it's not a good way to
analyze data okay
um what what is this um
oh yep this is a hierarchical edge
edge bundling plot um
i think this is pretty interesting i
think again it's
pretty much a variation of uh of the uh
of the chord quarter gram i think this
is a little bit cleaner
just to see like oh we have a little
group so i'll put it above right here
but again i don't think
maybe i guess these are pretty similar
so i don't know why they would be
this one is better than that one
actually might switch them where
uh oops or this is a little bit better
than that plot but again uh i'm not
really a big fan of them i don't use
them too often too so
maybe i'm just missing something so
the next one second last one is the
violin plot
uh i think violin pots are really cool
because violin plots are essentially
density plots flipped on its side and
mirrored
and one of the big criticisms of a
density plot
is that the mirroring effect kind of is
confusing
additionally it's it's pretty hard to
read for someone who's not really
familiar with the density plot
but i like density i like the violin
plots because
it shows a little bit more detail of a
gd plot
of a box plot while still maintaining
a lot of the clarity of a box plot
that being said um one of the biggest
criticism
is if you need more detail on a box plot
just plot like a gigi rig
a ridgeline plot right from from there
and i kind of agree with them
i kind of think that violin plots were a
hot trend
for a year and then people realized that
there's
alternatives to it but i i still enjoy
seeing a violin plot every now and then
i just don't use them anymore uh i i
definitely switch
more towards ridgeline pods so i'm
probably going to put them up to see i
think they're above a sankigram because
you'll probably see a violent pot more
often than it's sinking but but
it's not not the best plot not now that
there's more modern alternatives
so lastly we have the box plot
um box plot shows the quartiles or and
then you can also see the mean median
and outliers i love box plots i
it's probably one of my favorite plots
to look at and there's a lot of
use cases with them right you can
compare groups and their distributions
you can all see like oh would between
two groups which one has like the higher
median um that's very useful
additionally what you can do is add in
your gm points or so you can kind of
make almost like a scatter plot or
whatever
um and i think instead of having a
violin plot it's actually
nicer to have just a box pot and then
you put in gm jitter
with a height uh at zero so
the jitter the points can only go
widthwise and can't go vertically
so that way we can see you know the the
summary statistics
summary statistics summary statistics of
the outliers
quantiles median while also looking
where
is the distribution of all of our
samples so i love
box plots i think they're incredibly
useful and i use them
literally every day so i'm going to put
them right above here
i'm going to look at these just a little
bit more just see if i want to change
anything
um yeah so animation
chart i think i'm maybe i was a little
too too cruel on the animation chart
um i think this chart
is pretentious but actually still gives
some type of insight whereas the
the word cod doesn't i do think i'm
pretty against the
circular bar chart and obviously we're
gonna put
uh the pie chart up below actually just
because uh just uh
because of data visualization i'm gonna
put the pie chart all the way on the
bottom
um as for s tier i think bar charts are
the best
scatter plots are definitely good line
charts right here are very good
the ridgeline plot is it's extremely
useful
the box plot is extremely useful the
pairwise plot is the thing that i i
usually do a lot when i start my edas
density and histograms are are very good
i kind of
yeah no i i definitely use ridgeline
pods more than these guys and i use box
spots more than the
histogram stuff like that i think
lollipop charts are again
pretty good too networks are good area
stuff like that
i think one thing i'm thinking about
seeing right here is a lot of these
plots that i think are lower rated have
to do with a lot of like relationships
and processes
um and for me i just don't do a lot of
that stuff so i'm sure if
we have someone who is watching this
video like network analysis
they might disagree with me but i think
for a beginner you're not going to see
that a lot
um so yeah um here's my final tier list
i'll probably i'll post the link to
towards the
uh towards the tier maker website so you
can make your own to your list
and yeah i'll see you guys next time and
tidy on